>> RIGHT NOW, WE ARE GETTING
NEW INFORMATION ABOUT THE FOCUS
OF THE JANUARY 6TH ELECT
COMMITTEE THAT IS GOING BEYOND
TRUMP ALLIES, TO INCLUDE THE
INNER CIRCLE OF FORMER VICE
PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE.
OUR SPECIAL CORRESPONDENT JAMIE
IS HERE WITH HER EXCLUSIVE
REPORTING.
JAMIE, WHO IS THE COMMITTEE
TARGETING RIGHT NOW IN PENCE'S
INNER CIRCLE?
>> WOLF, THE COMMITTEE IS
INTERESTED IN AT LEAST 5
MEMBERS OF THE PENCE INNER
CIRCLE, ACCORDING TO 3 SOURCES
FAMILIAR WITH THE EFFORT.
I WORKED WITH OUR COLLEAGUES,
MIKE WARREN AND ZACH ON THIS,
WE ARE TOLD THAT SOME
INDIVIDUALS CLOSE TO PENCE MAY
ACTUALLY BE WILLING TO EITHER
VOLUNTARILY OR UNDER THE GUISE
OF A FRIENDLY SUBPOENA, TALK
WITH THE COMMITTEE.
ACCORDING TO OUR SOURCES, SOME
ARE ACTUALLY PROVING MORE
WILLING TO ENGAGE WITH THE
COMMITTEE THAT IS PREVIOUSLY
MADE PUBLIC.
AMONG THE AIDES WOLF, OUR,
FORMER CHIEF OF STAFF, MARC
SHORT, FORMER CHIEF COUNSEL
GREG JACOB, FORMER NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISER KEITH KELLOGG.
WE REACHED OUT TO THE AIDES WHO
EITHER DID NOT RESPOND, OR
DECLINED TO COMMENT.
CLEARLY, THEY WANT TO KEEP LOW
PROFILE, BUT WE DID HEAR FROM
HOUSE COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN BENNIE
THOMPSON WHO WENT ON THE RECORD
AND SAID THAT SOME ARE
COOPERATING.
HE SAID, SOME YES, AND SOME.
NO BUT, CLEARLY, WOLF, THE
COMMITTEE WANTS TO TALK TO
THESE PEOPLE, AND FOR THE FIRST
TIME, WE ARE HEARING THAT SOME
PENCE AIDES ARE ENGAGING WITH
THE COMMITTEE.
>> YOU KNOW, IT'S REALLY
INTERESTING, BECAUSE THERE ARE
SOME PEOPLE OUT THERE WHO WERE
VERY CLOSE, VERY CLOSE TO THE
VICE PRESIDENT.
AND THEIR INFORMATION,
POTENTIALLY, COULD BE VERY,
VERY CRITICAL,?
RIGHT >> SO LET'S TALK ABOUT
THESE 3.
THESE ARE THE INNER CIRCLE.
THEY HAVE CRITICAL INFORMATION.
THEY WERE FIRSTHAND WITNESSES
IN THE DAYS LEADING UP TO
JANUARY 6, AND JANUARY 6, ABOUT
HOW FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
HIS ALLIES WERE TRYING TO
PRESSURE PENCE TO OVERTURN THE
RESULTS OF THE ELECTION.
JUST TAKE A LOOK, MARC SHORT,
CHIEF OF STAFF, PENCE'S CLOSEST
AIDES, WITH HIM IN THE DAYS
LEADING UP TO JANUARY 6.
THE MEETINGS ACTUALLY WITH HIM,
ON JANUARY 6, UP AT THE
CAPITOL.
UNTIL THERE IS A LOT OF
INTERESTING --
2ND, GREG JACOB, FORMER CHIEF
COUNSEL.
JACOB WAS CRITICAL IN PUSHING
BACK ON ONE OF TRUMP'S LAWYERS
THAT WE NOW KNOW ABOUT, JOHN
EASTMAN, WHO WROTE THAT 2 PAGE
MEMO, TRYING TO JUSTIFY PENCE
STOPPING THE CERTIFICATION.
I AM TOLD THAT JACOB PLAYED
EQUIVOCAL ROLE IN COUNTERING
THOSE EFFORTS, AND AS A PERSON
OF SIGNIFICANT ENTRANCE TO THE
COMMITTEE.
FINALLY, AMONG THE GROUP, KEITH
KELLOGG, FORMER NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISER TO PENCE, WHO
ACTUALLY WAS WITH FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP, BOTH ON
JANUARY 6 --
BECAUSE NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISER BRYAN WAS OUT OF TIME.
KELLOGG OBSERVED FIRSTHAND
EXACTLY WHAT TRUMP WAS SAYING
AND DOING DURING THE CAPITOL
INSURRECTION.
THE COMMITTEE REALLY WANTS TO
TALK TO HIM, AND HE WAS JUST
THE PEANUT, WOLF.
>> IS THIS PROBLEMATIC, ALL
THIS REPORTING OF YOURS, FOR
PENCE'S POLITICAL FUTURE?
>> NO QUESTION.
THIS IS A POLITICAL TIGHT ROPE.
LOOK, IT'S NO SECRET THAT MIKE
PENCE WANTS TO RUN FOR
PRESIDENT, OR IS EXPLORING
THAT.
BUT ANY PUBLIC COOPERATION,
WITH THE JANUARY 6 COMMITTEE,
IS NOT GOING TO BE POPULAR WITH
TRUMP SPACE.
SO WHAT WE ARE SEEING HERE IN
PENCE WORLD, IS CLEARLY, THEY
ARE ENGAGING WITH THE
COMMITTEE.
AND THERE IS NO QUESTION THAT
THE COMMITTEE WANTS TO TALK TO
THEM.
BUT THEY DON'T WANT TO BE
PUBLIC, WOLF.
>> ALL RIGHT, JAMIE, I WANT YOU
TO STAY WITH US.
I WANNA BRING IN OUR CHIEF
LEGAL ANALYST JEFFREY TOOBIN.
HE IS THE AUTHOR OF
MISDEMEANORS, THE INVESTIGATION
OF DONALD TRUMP.
ALSO WITH US, CNN POLITICAL
ANALYST MAGGIE, A WASHINGTON
CORRESPONDENT FOR THE NEW YORK
TIMES.
MAGGIE, THERE IS BEEN SOME
SERIOUS TENSION AS WE KNOW,
BETWEEN FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP,
AND FORMER VICE PRESIDENT PENCE,
SINCE THE ATTACK THAT DAY.
WILL THE LEVEL OF COOPERATION
FROM PENCE AIDES REFLECT THAT?
>> WOLF, THERE'S ACTUALLY
WITHSTANDING BETWEEN PENCE AND
TRUMP DIRECTLY, DESPITE
EVERYTHING THAT HAPPENED THEN
THERE IS BETWEEN THE 2 CAMPS.
I DO THINK THAT THERE'S CISCO
INTO CAUSE MORE FRICTION, I
THINK THAT TRUMP IN PARTICULAR
DOES NOT WANT TO SEE PENCE'S
FOLKS GO TALK TO THE COMMITTEE.
THESE ARE NOT ALL IDENTICAL
ADVISERS.
KEITH KELLOGG, YES, HE WAS IN
THE OVAL OFFICE, BUT HE IS
WIDELY SEEN AMONG FRANCIS AIDES,
AND AMONG OUTSIDE THE PEN
CIRCLE, AS CANDIDLY MORE LOYAL
THAN TRUMP THEN TO PENCE.
SO AMONG THE QUESTIONS THAT
PEOPLE HAD, I UNDERSTAND THAT
ROBERT O'BRIEN WAS AT SOUTHCOM
THAT DAY, AND WAS NOT
AVAILABLE.
AND THAT'S WHY KELLOGG WAS
EXTENSIVELY THERE, BUT THE FACT
THAT COLOR WAS THERE IN THE
TANDEM AT THE RALLY, SERVING
ALL THESE THINGS, AND NOT
REALLY FOCUSING ON PENCE,
RAISED A LOT OF QUESTIONS.
I THINK YOU'RE GONNA SEE
SKEPTICISM WITHIN THE AIDS, AND
I DON'T QUITE KNOW WHAT'S GONNA
LOOK.
LIKE >> THAT'S A GOOD POINT.
JEFFREY, THE COMMITTEE SAYS
PENCE SAYS NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISER HAS WHAT THEY CALL
DIRECT INFORMATION ON FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S STATEMENTS
ABOUT AND REACTION TO THE
CAPITOL INSURRECTION.
HOW YOU SPOKE TO THESE
WITNESSES TO THIS OVERALL
INVESTIGATION?
>> WELL, THEY CAN BE VERY
USEFUL.
BUT THE KEY ISSUE IS, AS CHENEY
WAS POINTING OUT, SOME OF THEM
MAY ACTUALLY BE WILLING TO
TESTIFY, BECAUSE OF THE LEGAL
STRUCTURE OF HOW THIS
INVESTIGATION IS PROCEEDING.
ANYONE WHO DECIDES TO FIGHT
THESE SUBPOENAS IN COURT IS
LIKELY TO BE ABLE TO RUN OUT
THE CLOCK.
BUT IF THESE PENCE AIDES,
WILLINGLY TESTIFY, UNDER
SUBPOENA OR JUST WITHOUT A
SUBPOENA, THAT COULD BE OF
ENORMOUS BENEFIT TO THE
COMMITTEE.
BUT THEY ARE GONNA HAVE TO
DECIDE WHETHER THEY WANT TO
RISK THE RAFT OF TRUMP, AND
PARTICIPATE IN THE
INVESTIGATION AND TALK TO
INVESTIGATORS.
>> MAGGIE, ON TRUMP'S WHITE
HOUSE DOCUMENTS, YOU'VE HEARD
THAT FORCEFUL REJECTION OF
TRUMP'S ARGUMENTS, FROM THE
JUDGE, SAYING, AND I'M QUOTING
NOW, " PRESIDENTS ARE NOT KINGS,
AND PLAINTIFFS NOT PRESIDENT ".
THAT HAS TO BE HARMFUL FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP TO HAPPENS
RIGHT AROUND.
>> --
I CERTAINLY THINK THAT CARRYING
AN ILLEGAL DECISION IS NOT
GOING TO SIT WELL.
I THINK UNSURPRISINGLY, ARE
GOING TO SEE TRUMP CONTINUE
TRYING TO FIGHT THIS, AS
JEFFREY SAID, THERE IS A
RUNNING OUT THE CLOCK STRATEGY
HERE.
HIS FOLKS TALK ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF TRYING TO SET
LEGAL PRECEDENT, RELATED TO
FORMER PRESIDENT, AN EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE, AND THAT'S I'M.
BUT THIS IS ALSO A STRATEGY
TRUMP USES MANY TIMES.
NONE OF THIS, YOU, KNOW IS
HELPFUL TO TRUMP IN TERMS OF IT
SIMPLY REMINDING HIM THAT HE IS
NOT PRESIDENT ANYMORE.
HE HAS, HOWEVER WOLF, I WOULD
POINT OUT, BEGUN THIS VERY
AGGRESSIVE EFFORT TO TRY TO
REWRITE WHAT TOOK PLACE ON
JANUARY 6, REWRITE WHAT WAS
HAPPENING AT THE CAPITOL, WE
WRITE WHY IT WAS TAKING PLACE,
WE WRITE WHETHER THERE WAS
VIOLENCE OR NIGHT.
AND I THINK THAT THAT IS TAKING
PLACE IN FRONT OF OUR EYES, AS
THE JUSTICE COMMITTEE
WITNESSES.
>> JEFFREY, THE TRUMP LEGAL
TEAM CLEARLY IS APPEALING ALL
OF THIS.
HOW WILL THAT WORK, AND WILL
ANY OF THE STOP THESE DOCUMENTS
FROM BEING HANDED TO THE HOUSE
OF REPRESENTATIVES BY FRIDAY?
>> YOU KNOW, THIS IS THE FIRST
MOMENT WHERE THE COMMITTEE,
REALLY, HAS THE UPPERHAND,
LEGALLY.
BECAUSE THEY NOW HOLD AND THEIR
HANDS A DECISION FROM THE
DISTRICT COURT IN WASHINGTON,
SAYING THAT THE NATIONAL
ARCHIVES HAS THE START TURNING
OVER THESE DOCUMENTS ON FRIDAY.
SO, THE STATUS QUO MEANS THE
COMMITTEE GETS THE DOCUMENTS.
THE ISSUE HERE IS WHAT WILL THE
D.C. CIRCUIT TO?
THE COURT OF APPEALS FOR THE
D.C. CIRCUIT, THEY WILL BE
ASKED TO ISSUE A STAY, AND IT'S
ENORMOUSLY IMPORTANT.
BECAUSE IF THEY DON'T ISSUE A
STAY, IT MEANS THAT THE
COMMITTEE WILL START TO --
THE DOCUMENTS START TO BE
PRODUCED.
IF THEY DO ISSUE A STAY, IT
LIKELY MEANS MONTHS OF DELAY.
SO IN THE NEXT 24 TO 48 HOURS,
WE SHOULD KNOW WHETHER THIS
STAYS AN ISSUE, AND IT'S
ENORMOUSLY IMPORTANT FOR THE
FUTURE OF THIS INVESTIGATION
AND HOW THAT GOES.
>> JAMIE, SOME OF THESE
HIGH-PROFILE WITNESSES DON'T
COOPERATE, HOW COULD IT BE FOR
THE COMMITTEE TO SEE THOSE
WHITE HOUSE DOCUMENTS, CALL
LOGS, SCHEDULES, EVEN
HANDWRITTEN NOTES?
>> ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL.
THIS IS EXACTLY THE KIND OF
PIECES OF THE PUZZLE THAT COULD
LEAD IN SOME PLACE.
AND I JUST WANT TO SAY ONE
OTHER THING ABOUT ENGAGING WITH
THE COMMITTEE.
SOME PEOPLE MAY AGREE TO
TESTIFY.
SOME PEOPLE MAY COME UP WITH
SUBPOENAS.
BUT WE MAY SEE SOME OF THESE
PEOPLE